it's just past 10 GMT and we start with
breaking news from Pakistan at least 15
people have been killed and dozens more
are injured after a Train derailed in
the Southeastern synth Province ten
carriages of the hazada express
reportedly came off the tracks officials
say the cause isn't yet clear let's go
straight to our Pakistan correspondent
Kamal Haider he's joining us live from
Islamabad what more are you hearing
about the accident command
when we are hearing that this train the
Hazara Express which was traveling from
Karachi to the city of Raul Pindi it met
with this derailment about
275 kilometers away from Karachi at a
place called nawabza uh the train
station it was approaching is in a
remote area it took about uh an hour and
a half for the First Responders rescue
teams to arrive to pull those people out
of the wreckage of 15 people now
confirmed dead dozens of them injured so
indeed an emergency situation those who
were wounded have been rushed to a
hospital in nawabza medical facilities
in such areas and north at their best
even and the best of times so there will
be a concern that the casualties could
rise all right kamalan just how often do
these kinds of accidents happen in
Pakistan
well Pakistan Railways is neglected it
has become obsolete it's one of the most
corrupt organizations in the country a
track record is not good at all Pakistan
has seen frequent deadly accidents of
trains and despite promises has not done
much to rewamp the railway system now
there are talks between Pakistan and
China to build brand new lines but that
will take several years and until then
of course people will always run the
risk of traveling in these trains which
have become extremely dangerous because
of the poor shape of the tracks not to
mention the equipment which had become
obsolete all right Simone thank you for
that that is Kamal Hyder with what we
know so far about this train derailment
in synth province